Let's go through them. This one has the red dot right at the beginning, and it's coming from state 0.
This is a state that will occur in our chart, but it occurs in chart state 0.
Similarly, this one is coming from position 0. We've seen the a. We haven't seen the s or the b.
This one will be there, but it's in chart 1, and we're looking for things in chart 2.
S goes to nothing from 1, and I haven't quite seen it yet.
This won't be in chart state 2 because only one input token is accounted for.
This is still in chart state 1, but over here, this is looking very promising.
This is saying we've just finished reducing s goes to c,
and there's one more token before this that you haven't seen.
Here, we're reducing s goes to c, and here's one token before this not currently shown.
This will be in chart state 2.
Now, these last two really test your memory of how we compute the parsing states,
the charts, and how we keep track of this from information.
This one looks very tempting. S goes to as.b, that's definitely where we are in the input.
We're right before the b, but it says from 1.
That means there has to be one more input character that we haven't seen, x a c,
but that's not the input we're currently seeing.
There's no other hidden character that's not shown here.
Instead, the one we really want is as.b from 0. This is the beginning of the string.
There's an a, s goes to c. This is where we are now.
And we're hoping to see b. That's definitely in chart 2.